hey I'm Michael Bay and I am a strong
believer in protecting the sentiment
experience this is my edit room here in
my house in Miami I love cutting here
because it's quiet this whole system
pipes to Santa Monica where I have 5
editors go by anyway those my editors
and connect it with like different room
they can see what I do on my system here
we can share screens a great way to work
moving like transformers need to be seen
using the very finest tools the best
sound technology best projection
technology 2 cameras I'm here to keep 3d
a lot I'm the only way to make it the
best experience for you is to shoot it
natively that means two cameras two eyes
but see exactly what you're seeing we're
the first movie to ever shoot IMAX 3d we
place these two gigantic cameras on top
of each other to give you an amazing
resolution
select your eyes you see depth it's
beautiful and it's something you cannot
fake we're going to spend the extra 10
to 15 billion dollars and we're going to
do it right we're in fact the only movie
this summer it was shot in native 3d
what image like this to post convert
virtually impossible see those dealing
the little particles here they have to
capture each one of those and put them a
different space whereas when you shoot
it natively it's already doing that for
you the scale of the Transformers movie
is meant to be seen thanks
with great sound and brightly lit 3d
screens Michael is always on the cutting
edge of technology for the audience to
have them have a more visceral
experience is filmmaking as a very
three-dimensional style Transformers has
many giant part of our brand it helped
build I'm Michael is the very first
filmmaker to take two of these cameras
and configure the Amana 3d rig and shoot
intrigued me in real time and that's not
trivial the resolution the detail the
clarity it really is mind-boggling
there's a lock on the shoot I keep
saying that's my last one and I'm going
out for the bank this is a big scale
you
you